[Applause]  i just want to bring you some breaking  news of course uh we're so used to now  at five o'clock on a thursday getting an  update from the transport secretary on  those countries that are  or are not in our travel corridor and uh  he has updated us in the last few  moments that  the latest data he says shows us that we  need to remove  denmark slovakia iceland and curacao  that is the caribbean island in the  dutch caribbean sea  from the travel corridor list and it  goes on to say if you arrive in the uk  from these destinations after 4am on  saturday  you will need to self-isolate for 14  days  and he also says we will not be adding  any destinations to the safe  travel corridor list this week but as i  say denmark slovakia iceland and  kurosawa  will now require people to self-isolate  for 14 days as of saturday